i think one significant development
antonio brown limited in practice a good
sign that he'll be able to play they
don't need him but man if they have him
that's a much better offense given the
way that he performed down the stretch
yeah no question mike and he leads a
team in targets when he's played
obviously he played eight regular season
games in the first two postseason games
and then missed the nfc championship
game but he can be a factor in this game
the last time he was in the super bowl
was his rookie season he had one catch
for one yard i listened to his entire
press conference today he was
non-committal whether he'd be able to
play or not but i would expect him to be
out there if he can go at all and
considering he was limited today in
practice mike i think he will be able to
go
you know i also saw some tweets in which
uh he was characterized as painting
himself as a victim for the challenges
he's faced
he
he's not
the victim he now now look are there
other issues
that have caused him to engage in
certain anti-social behaviors over the
past couple of years i'm willing to
grant him that possibility i'm willing
to say that he hasn't consciously and
deliberately been
a jerk that he consciously and
deliberately hasn't been someone who did
things that
have gotten him in trouble but still
he's responsible ultimately and
fundamentally for the adversity that
he's faced this isn't something that
someone else unfairly threw upon him
again it may be the product of some
condition that requires treatment
evaluation
but
it's no one else's fault
other than his so that bothers me and i
think a lot of people are bothered by
that and i have no problem with a
redemption story
but i don't think
you qualify for redemption shireen if
you never acknowledge that at some level
you're responsible for what's happened
and therefore qualify for redemption you
don't qualify for redemption until you
acknowledge that you need to be redeemed
yeah and i think all these redempt
redemption stories that we're reading
and hearing about mike i do think we
have to remember that he's not the
victim here definitely not and i'll give
him this
he's done everything presumably and he
talked about this in his interview today
the right way since he's come to tampa
so i hope he's gotten the help he needed
as he says he has and that things have
turned around in his life i do hope that
i hope that for any player i don't care
if i like the player or don't like the
player i hope any player that wants to
turn his life around that's the most
important thing so i hope he's done that
but let's all remember mike he is not
the victim here
now all of the injured buccaneers
practiced with the exception of jason
pierre paul who has a knee injury other
guys who are
who are questionable not officially yet
we won't find out until friday but at
least unofficially questionable for now
you've got levante david with the
hamstring injury there is the
ankle problem for antoine winfield jr
and jordan whitehead the shoulder injury
he suffered in the nfc championship but
all practiced on a limited basis except
jpp
for the chiefs everyone except eric
fisher who has a ruptured achilles
tendon
and willie gay who i think whatever
happened to him i can't remember what it
was shireen but i think he's out already
i don't think he's going to play but all
of the other chiefs practiced
yeah that's right mike and so both teams
are pretty much going to be at full
strength aside you know we've talked a
lot about that chief's offensive line
and they're going to move the parts
around mike rumors obviously we'll start
at left tackle and they won't have eric
fisher they won't have mitchell schwartz
so that offensive line is going to look
a little bit different but for the most
part for the players we expect to have i
think we're going to see those players
on the field on sunday important for the
bucks as we said repeatedly to have
those two starting safeties out there
because they do make a difference
yeah absolutely and that chief's
receiving core is going to test the
defense especially on the back end
repeatedly and if it's anything like it
was in week 12
they better be ready to go and they
better not single cover tyrek hill
because he had i think he was on pace
for a thousand yards for the entire game
halfway through the first quarter tony
romo exaggerated that or at least he
thought he did peter king did the math
it was like 998 that tyreke hill was on
pace for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports